you've come from Ethiopia where were you
born when I was seven years old my
parents took me to a Sufi shrine they
left me there they never came back the
refugee or a federal agency will arrange
for long-term housing when will she be
back see once I didn't know them then
you have a lot to learn
must be nice to have this place all to
yourself I didn't ask for it
you didn't have to when we come together
we tell each other our stories I don't
have much to tell
do you know this man who is the doctor
to you come away with me
just say yes
[Music]
the house has been washed if I'm taken
they might come for you next time I
promise I'll come find you
[Music]
the soldiers beat him until he was broke
in the hospital live he won't be able to
look at me doing excellent work yes
that was meant to be a compliment how do
we find each other
the Ethiopian family reunification
Association no such thing
how that is now we can do this together
I need to know you are somewhere safe
hah my heart a very old friend
[Music]
[Music]
you are full of surprises
English cat
[Music]
you